I grew up in Baltimore. And I remember in the 1970s, at a very low moment, the city commissioned a slogan and a song and an ad campaign called Charm City, USA. And at the time, Baltimore was grimy and run down and still recovering from the riots and white flight of the 1960s. I have never met a single person who took this slogan seriously.
我在巴尔的摩长大。我记得在20世纪70年代，城市处于非常低谷的时候，市政府征集了一条口号、一首歌和一个名为“魅力之城，美国”的广告宣传活动。当时，巴尔的摩又脏又破，还在从20世纪60年代的骚乱和白人逃离中恢复。我从来没有见过有哪个人会认真对待这个口号。
And I always thought that that's how it goes. Right? My wife has told me how pathetic Detroit's slogan, "Say Nice Things About Detroit," seemed to her even as a kid. That's where she's from. This kind of forced boosterism arrives precisely when things are at their worst in a city.
我一直觉得事情就是这样，对吧？我妻子告诉过我，即使在她小时候，底特律那个“说说底特律的好话”的口号对她来说显得多么可怜。那是她的家乡。这种强加的吹捧往往出现在城市最糟糕的时候。
So I wondered if there are actually cities where these campaigns work. And somebody told me that Calgary, Canada, was a place like that. And we looked for a born-and-bred Calgarian to tell us whether or not it was true. And that is how we found Ken Lima-Coelho. And he said yes. He said back in the '80s, they had a feel good song. At the time, he says, they only had three TV channels, and it was on two of them.
所以我很好奇是否真的有城市因为这些活动而好转。有人告诉我，加拿大的卡尔加里就是这样一个地方。我们找了一位土生土长的卡尔加里人来告诉我们这是不是真的。于是我们找到了肯·利马-科埃略。他说确实如此。他说在80年代，他们有一首让人感觉很好的歌。他说那时候他们只有三个电视频道，其中两个都在播放这首歌。
So I've probably heard it-- I'm not even exaggerating-- 1,000 times. Everybody knew it. Everybody knew it. And there was this kind of weird pride around the song. And I actually remember that. We used to sing this with our friends. And my mom used to talk about this song.
所以我可能听过——我一点也没夸张——1000遍。每个人都知道它。每个人都知道。而且这首歌周围有一种奇怪的自豪感。我真的记得。我们过去常和朋友一起唱这首歌。我妈妈也常提起这首歌。
Wait. You would sing this song with your friends?
等等。你会和朋友一起唱这首歌吗？
Oh yeah. Absolutely. And somebody would start, and we would sing it, and we'd all laugh. I loved it. I loved it then. I kind of love it now. Just when you hear that "bling," those first little strains of the mel-- I'm right back there.
哦，是的。绝对会。有人起个头，我们就会跟着唱，然后大家都笑起来。我喜欢它。那时候我喜欢它。现在我也还是有点喜欢。只要听到那个“叮”的一声，听到旋律最初的一点点声响——我就立刻回到那个时候了。
[MUSIC - "HELLO CALGARY"]
[音乐 - “你好，卡尔加里”]
Of course, there was a video, which at the time seemed very fresh and new.
当然，还有一段视频，在当时看来非常新鲜和新颖。
Kind of a prairie scene. And there's this beautiful sunset. A guy throws a football at McMahon Stadium, which is our big football stadium. And the guy who's supposed to catch it gets bonked on the head. It's really cheesy.
那是一种大草原的场景。夕阳很美。一个家伙在我们的足球大体育场麦克马洪体育场扔橄榄球。那个本该接球的家伙被砸到了脑袋。真的很老套。
[MUSIC - "HELLO CALGARY"]
[音乐 - “你好，卡尔加里”]
Do you have a favorite part of this song?
这首歌你有最喜欢的片段吗？
Oh yeah. Right here.
哦，有。就在这里。
[MUSIC - "HELLO CALGARY"]
[音乐 - “你好，卡尔加里”]
Ha? She's just giving her.
哈？她只是在给它。
[MUSIC - "HELLO CALGARY"]
[音乐 - “你好，卡尔加里”]
Did the song seem cheesy at the time?
当时觉得这首歌老套吗？
No. The song seemed very genuine at the time.
不。当时觉得这首歌非常真诚。
Early in our interview, I asked him if he knew any of the words, and he sang me the entire song from memory perfectly. He says now and then, one of his friends will post the song to Facebook. It was a really big deal back then, he says, because before then, Calgary didn't have much pride at all. The city wasn't doing great. Their nearby archrival, Edmonton, which was smaller, and which he'd been raised to think of as a poorer cousin, seemed to get all the glory.
在采访初期，我问他是否记得歌词，他凭记忆完美地唱出了整首歌。他说现在偶尔会有朋友把这首歌发到Facebook上。他说那时候这事真的很重要，因为在那之前，卡尔加里根本没什么自豪感。城市发展得并不好。他们附近的劲敌埃德蒙顿，规模更小，他从小就被教育认为那是更穷的亲戚，却似乎抢走了所有的风头。
You have to remember, at the time, Edmonton was it. They had the Edmonton Oilers, the most famous hockey team on the planet-- Wayne Gretzky. They won four Stanley Cups. They had a sign, as you drove into Edmonton, that said "Edmonton, city of champions." And that drove us crazy. I mean, they did win every Stanley Cup in the era. But that drove us really nuts.
你得记住，在当时，埃德蒙顿才是焦点。他们有埃德蒙顿油人队，地球上最著名的冰球队——韦恩·格雷茨基。他们赢得了四次斯坦利杯。当你开车进入埃德蒙顿时，有一个牌子写着“埃德蒙顿，冠军之城”。这让我们快疯了。我是说，他们确实赢得了那个时代所有的斯坦利杯。但那真的让我们非常抓狂。
And then here comes this song that oozes pride. And it sort of captured the spirit of, hey, ya, we are the best hometown we know. Darn it.
然后这首歌出现了，它充满了自豪感。它捕捉到了那种精神，嘿，是的，我们是我们所知的最好的家乡。该死。
So Ken, now, I want to play you something else. And I think you've never heard this.
所以肯，现在，我想给你放点别的东西。我想你从来没听过这个。
[MUSIC - "HELLO MILWAUKEE"]
[音乐 - “你好，密尔沃基”]
[LAUGHS] Milwaukee?
[笑] 密尔沃基？
This is the original song that the Calgary song is based on.
这是卡尔加里那首歌所基于的原版歌曲。
What do you-- really?
你——真的吗？
Yeah, it was Milwaukee first. And then we're told by the songwriter-- he can't remember if Utah was second or Calgary was second.
是的，最先是密尔沃基。然后词曲作者告诉我们——他不记得犹他排第二还是卡尔加里排第二。
[MUSIC - "HELLO MILWAUKEE"]
[音乐 - “你好，密尔沃基”]
Whoa, whoa, whoa. How can there be two best hometowns I know? That can't be right. I'm glad they didn't use the same woman, though. That would have been really bad.
哇，哇，哇。怎么可能有两个我所知的最好的家乡？那肯定不对。不过我很高兴他们没用同一个女人。那真的会很糟。
Let me play you something else now.
现在让我给你放点别的东西。
[MUSIC - "HELLO PITTSBURGH"]
[音乐 - “你好，匹兹堡”]
[MUSIC - "HELLO INDIANA"]
[音乐 - “你好，印第安纳”]
[GUFFAWS] No!
[大笑] 不！
[MUSIC - "HELLO PHOENIX"]
[音乐 - “你好，菲尼克斯”]
[MUSIC - "HELLO TULSA"]
[音乐 - “你好，塔尔萨”]
[MUSIC - "HELLO ROCHESTER"]
[音乐 - “你好，罗切斯特”]
Oh my-- ah! I don't know what to say.
天哪——啊！我不知道该说什么。
[MUSIC - "HELLO ATLANTA"]
[音乐 - “你好，亚特兰大”]
How many versions are there?
到底有多少个版本？
There are over 100.
有100多个。
[MUSIC - "HELLO KNOXVILLE"]
[音乐 - “你好，诺克斯维尔”]
Ken said that he was 2/3 bemused by all this and 1/3 actually sort of mad. He had really thought of it as Calgary's song.
肯说他对此感到三分之二的困惑，三分之一实际上有点生气。他真的以为这是卡尔加里的歌。
For me, this is like finding out that your childhood teddy bear was owned by three other people on the weekends when you weren't there. I don't know.
对我来说，这就像发现你童年的泰迪熊在你不在的时候被另外三个人拥有过。我不知道。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
You know what would really get me? There isn't a "Hello Edmonton," is there?
你知道什么会真正惹恼我吗？没有“你好，埃德蒙顿”，对吧？
No, there isn't.
没有，确实没有。
And Ken does not begrudge the song's composer his success at selling the song in all these different cities. He just felt dirty and betrayed by this song that claims that each city is unique and special, but then, by telling 100 other cities the same thing, proves that the opposite is true. When we tracked down the song's creator, a guy named Frank Gari, no relation to the architect, I was surprised when he described the customization that he said that he gave to each city's version of "Hello."
肯并不嫉妒这首歌的作曲家在所有这些不同城市销售歌曲的成功。他只是觉得被这首歌弄得脏兮兮且受到了背叛，这首歌声称每个城市都是独特而特别的，但后来通过告诉其他100个城市同样的事情，证明了事实恰恰相反。当我们找到这首歌的创作者，一个叫弗兰克·加里的人（他与那位建筑师没有关系）时，我很惊讶他描述了所谓的给每个城市的“你好”版本所做的定制。
Listening to a few dozen of the songs, the only changes that I found were that he would change the name of the city. And then usually, he would just change one geographic detail. So "from the mountains close at hand" would become "from the golden countryside" or "from the bayfront shore" in places where there were no mountains. Though he described his process this way.
听了几十首这种歌，我发现唯一的改动就是他会更改城市的名字。然后通常他只会更改一个地理细节。所以“近在咫尺的山峦”在没有山的地方会变成“金色的乡村”或“海滨岸边”。尽管他这样描述他的过程。
I would fly to the city. I would meet with the people, study the area, location, the lay of the land, the people. And that would inspire me to write the lyric, the new lyric, the new customization. It was really a geography history class. I learned a tremendous a lot about this country.
我会飞到那个城市。我会与当地人会面，研究该地区、位置、地形、人民。这会激发我写出歌词、新的歌词、新的定制内容。这真的是一堂地理历史课。我学到了很多关于这个国家的知识。
Frank Gari said that actually they usually would not change the lyrics that much because the feelings in the song were so universal. He said feeling pride about Calgary is not so different from feeling pride about Baltimore or feeling pride about Detroit.
弗兰克·加里说，实际上他们通常不会改动太多歌词，因为歌里的情感是如此普遍。他说，对卡尔加里感到自豪与对巴尔的摩感到自豪，或者对底特律感到自豪，并没有什么不同。
You know, it's the same. It's the same. It may be snowing in one area, and it might be 80 degrees in another. But people are people, and they're going through the same-- absolutely. And that's the same thing with keeping certain parts of the song.
你知道，这都是一样的。这都是一样的。一个地区可能在下雪，另一个可能有80华氏度。但人就是人，他们经历着同样的——绝对。保留歌曲的某些部分也是一样的道理。
I mean, it's funny. I think the fact that this works, that you could have a song and have all of these local places attach, and have people really like it in all these local places, I feel like it really shows that people want to connect with a song like that.
我是说，这很有趣。我认为这之所以有效，即你可以有一首歌，让所有这些地方建立联系，并让人们在所有这些地方真正喜欢它，我觉得这确实表明人们想要与这样一首歌连接起来。
Well, there's no question about that. I mean, people want to attach to a positive vibe about the place where they live. Absolutely, absolutely. That's what "Hello" did. And that's what we tried to incorporate.
嗯，这一点毫无疑问。我是说，人们想要对他们居住的地方产生一种积极的共鸣。绝对，绝对。这就是“你好”所做的。也是我们试图融入的东西。
Lots of people, of course, have very strong feelings about where they live. And lots of people will, of course, do all kinds of things to hold onto that feeling of place. And today on our program, we have three stories of people doing some very unusual things, including, for example, staging an exit from their own country, though all in pretend, as a way to stay in their country and their hometown.
当然，很多人对他们居住的地方有着非常强烈的感情。很多人当然会做各种事情来留住那种地方感。今天在我们的节目中，我们有三个关于人们做一些非常不寻常的事情的故事，其中包括，例如，策划一场离开自己国家的行动，尽管全是假装的，作为一种留在他们国家和家乡的方式。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》，由公共广播国际发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, Flight Simulation. For lots of small towns in Mexico, so many people leave that leaving becomes one of the defining parts of being from there, even the people that have strong ties to home and family members who stayed behind. James Spring went to a town like that recently in Mexico for an event organized by the people who stayed behind.
第一幕，飞行模拟。对于墨西哥的许多小城镇来说，离开的人太多了，以至于离开成了来自那里的人的定义性部分，即使是那些与家乡和留在身后的家人有紧密联系的人也是如此。詹姆斯·斯普林最近去了墨西哥一个那样的城镇，参加了由留下来的人组织的活动。
A lot of people are going to yell at me tonight. One of them is this guy, Mateo. He's 19, and he's rolling past me in a pickup truck with blue and red flashing lights.
今晚很多人会对我大喊大叫。其中一个是这个家伙，马特奥。他19岁，正开着一辆闪烁着蓝红灯光的皮卡车从我身边经过。
Come out with your hands up. I want to  see your hands up. [SPEAKING SPANISH]
把手举起来出来。我要看到你们举起手。[说西班牙语]
There's a US Border Control emblem on the door of the pickup. But it's fake. Just like Mateo's Border Patrol uniform. We're hundreds of miles from the actual US border in a tiny Mexican village. It's called El Alberto. And it's known for a really specific kind of tourist attraction, a simulated illegal nighttime border crossing. They call it the Caminata Nocturna, the Night Hike.
皮卡车的门上有一个美国边境管制标志。但它是假的。就像马特奥的边境巡逻制服一样。我们距离真正的美国边境几百英里远，在一个小小的墨西哥村庄里。它叫埃尔阿尔贝托。它以一种非常特殊的旅游景点而闻名，即模拟非法夜间越境。他们称之为“夜间步行”。
I'm the first one here. So I'm just standing around with 40 or 50 locals, all of them dressed up in their costumes. Fake border agents wearing Vietnam-era camo, blinged out drug cartel thugs, and migrants, and human smugglers.
我是第一个到这里的。所以我只是站在40或50个当地人中间，他们都穿着戏服。假扮的边境特工穿着越战时期的迷彩服，戴着首饰的贩毒集团暴徒，还有移民和人口走私贩。
A few years ago in the US, there were some news reports about the Caminata, and right wing blogs jumped all over it. They accused the organizers here of running a training camp for illegal migrants. But most of the people who go on the Caminata are middle class Mexicans and university students, people who can afford the 200 peso ticket, about $16, people who would probably never need to actually sneak into the US.
几年前在美国，有一些关于“夜间步行”的新闻报道，右翼博客对此大肆抨击。他们指责这里的组织者在经营一个非法移民训练营。但参加“夜间步行”的大多数人是中产阶级墨西哥人和大学生，那些付得起200比索门票的人，大约16美元，那些可能永远不需要真的潜入美国的人。
For instance, tonight, we're waiting for a group of salespeople from Mexico City that's coming to do the Caminata as a [SPANISH], a corporate team building exercise. The people in costume are joking around with each other. And I speak Spanish, but I don't get any of the jokes, because they're not speaking Spanish.
例如，今晚，我们正在等待一群来自墨西哥城的销售人员，他们来参加“夜间步行”，作为一种企业团建活动。穿着戏服的人们互相开玩笑。我懂西班牙语，但我听不懂任何笑话，因为他们说的不是西班牙语。
These are the Hnahnu, an ancient tribe, here since long before the Aztecs. They run the Caminata on their land, which is a federal territory grant, almost like an Indian reservation in the United States. The land isn't much good for farming or cattle, and there are almost no paying jobs in El Alberto.
这些是哈纳胡人，一个古老的部落，在阿兹特克人之前就来到这里了。他们在他们的土地上进行“夜间步行”，这是联邦领土拨款，有点像美国的印第安保留地。这片土地不适合耕种或放牧，埃尔阿尔贝托几乎没有付薪的工作。
So at some point, the Hnahnu became experts at crossing the border into the US. Pretty much everyone around me now, they've done the real crossing, many of them multiple times. And it's been killing the village.
所以在某个时刻，哈纳胡人成为了穿越边境进入美国的专家。现在我身边的每个人，几乎都经历过真正的越境，很多人还不止一次。这一直在扼杀这个村庄。
There are only about 2,500 of the El Alberto Hnahnu left in the world. And 80% of them now live in the US in Vegas, around Arizona and Utah. The Caminata Nocturna is part of the Hnahnu elders' plan to turn the villagers' expertise-- leaving-- into a money maker so that the villagers will stay.
世界上只剩下大约2500名埃尔阿尔贝托哈纳胡人了。他们中80%的人现在住在美国的拉斯维加斯，以及亚利桑那州和犹他州周边。 “夜间步行”是哈纳胡长老计划的一部分，旨在将村民们的专长——离开——变成一种赚钱工具，以便村民们能留下来。
Hello, hello, hello.
你好，你好，你好。
A guy named Brigilio is one of the Hnahnu who's playing a migrant. He's 33, lanky, with a wisp of a mustache. He's going to be my own personal crossing buddy tonight.
一个叫布里吉里奥的家伙是扮演移民的哈纳胡人之一。他33岁，身材细长，留着一撮胡子。他今晚将成为我个人的越境伙伴。
I'm wearing these clothes. Are these clothes going to work OK? Is this--
我穿着这些衣服。这些衣服能行吗？这是——
Yeah, looks good.
是的，看起来不错。
During his four border crossings through the desert into Arizona, Brigilio's been robbed at gunpoint, had a knife held to his gut. He showed me the scar. Other people that he's crossed with have faced worse.
在他四次穿过沙漠进入亚利桑那州的越境过程中，布里吉里奥曾遭到持枪抢劫，刀子抵在肚子上。他给我看了伤疤。和他一起越境的其他人的遭遇更糟。
One of my friend, her hands-- como se dice?
我的一个朋友，她的手——怎么说？
Broke?
断了？
No.
不。
Sprained?
扭伤了？
Get paralyzed?
瘫痪了？
Oh. Was it from the cold?
哦。是因为冷吗？
Yeah, from the cold.
是的，因为冷。
Frostbitten.
冻伤了。
Frostbite.
冻伤。
One of Brigilio's cousins was in a pickup that was chased by the Border Patrol. The truck rolled over, and his cousin died. Brigilio says there's no way to plan for every danger on a border crossing.
布里吉里奥的一个表亲坐在一辆被边境巡逻队追赶的皮卡车里。卡车翻车了，他的表亲死了。布里吉里奥说，越境时的每一种危险都无法计划。
When the cartels come, we don't know what's going to happen. Or when the gangsters come to us, sometimes you'll see a beautiful girl or a woman, sometimes violate these women. Or sometime, undress-- como se dice? Undress?
当贩毒集团来的时候，我们不知道会发生什么。或者当黑帮来找我们时，有时你会看到一个漂亮的女孩或女人，有时会侵犯这些女人。或者有时，脱掉——怎么说？脱掉衣服？
Mhm.
嗯。
Undress the clothes in front of the group. Or touch her. That happened to my kids, one of my kids. And--
在人群面前脱掉衣服。或者触摸她。这发生在我孩子身上，我的一个孩子。而且——
She's OK.
她没事。
Brigilio told me he never wants to do the crossing again. I believe him. He looks exhausted just talking about it. But he says he doesn't mind faking it for the Caminata.
布里吉里奥告诉我，他再也不想越境了。我相信他。光是谈论这件事他就看起来精疲力竭。但他说他不介意为“夜间步行”伪装一下。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Brigilio asks me in Spanish if we're going to turn off his mic. I tell him we're just going to leave it on. Because the salespeople are going to arrive any minute, right? He's been getting updates on a VHF radio. Yes, he says, they'll be here in a few minutes. The salespeople are a few minutes away for more than two hours.
布里吉里奥用西班牙语问我是不是要关掉他的麦克风。我告诉他我们只是让它开着。因为销售人员随时都会到达，对吧？他一直通过甚高频无线电接收更新。是的，他说，他们几分钟后就会到。销售人员距离这里几分钟路程持续了两个多小时。
It's just past 10:30 at night when their bus arrives. The sales team disembarks, men and women, about 50 of them, bearing zero apologies. Just a sea of polo shirts embroidered with the name of a big international corporation. Most of the Hnahnu actors have long since taken their positions out on the trail. The lead coyote, a short wiry guy, doesn't waste any time.
当他们的巴士抵达时，已经是晚上10点半刚过。销售团队下车了，男人和女人，大约50人，毫无歉意。只是一片穿着绣有大国际公司名称的Polo衫的人海。大多数哈纳胡演员早已在步道上就位。领头的“郊狼”（走私客），一个矮小精干的家伙，一点时间也没浪费。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Do any of you know what the Caminata Nocturna is, he asks. The salespeople do not. They make stupid guesses. I hate them.
你们有人知道什么是“夜间步行”吗，他问。销售人员不知道。他们乱猜。我讨厌他们。
The coyote is all business. He explains our objective. Tells us all that he and his pals will be leading us across the border this very night. But crossing the line is not the hard part. No, that's just the first step. After that, the trek will be tough, fraught with danger.
“郊狼”非常务实。他解释了我们的目标。告诉我们所有人，他和他的伙伴们今晚将带领我们越过边境。但越过那条线不是最难的部分。不，那只是第一步。在那之后，跋涉将非常艰难，充满危险。
The salespeople look more like they've prepared to trek to the lobby bar of a Radisson. One of the saleswomen asks if we're going to have to negotiate any stairs along the way, because stairs might present a problem for her. I look to Brigilio to see if he hates these people as much as I do, but he gives me nothing.
销售人员看起来更像是准备去丽笙酒店的大堂酒吧。其中一位女销售员问路上是否需要爬楼梯，因为楼梯可能会对她造成问题。我看向布里吉里奥，看他是否像我一样讨厌这些人，但他什么也没给我。
The coyote tries to impress upon all of us the gravity of the situation. Crossing the border is only for the most desperate of souls.
“郊狼”试图让我们所有人了解情况的严重性。越过边境只属于最绝望的灵魂。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
No.
不。
He asks us if we're desperate. The salespeople don't get it.
他问我们是否绝望。销售人员没明白。
No? [SPEAKING SPANISH]
不？[说西班牙语]
The coyote says we can stay here all night then. It takes asking them three times, but the group finally agrees to be desperate.
“郊狼”说那我们整晚都待在这里好了。问了他们三次，团队终于同意表现出绝望。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Si.
是的。
So the coyotes introduce themselves.
所以“郊狼”们介绍了自己。
El Chiquilin.
埃尔奇基林。
Chiquilin, El Guero, El Tigre. The salespeople clap after each one, like they're being introduced to Bob in Accounting. And then, in an instant, everything changes.
奇基林，埃尔格罗，埃尔蒂格雷。销售人员在每一个人介绍后都鼓掌，就像他们被介绍给会计部的鲍勃一样。然后，瞬间，一切都变了。
[SHOUTING]
[大喊]
Let's go, James, let's go!
走吧，詹姆斯，走吧！
The coyotes start yelling for us to get down low. It's time to move. We all run willy-nilly, like lunatics rushing the asylum gate. Brigilio and I are pretty fast. We pass a dozen of the saleswomen. Chiquilin, the lead coyote, signals for us to follow him behind a bluff where we all hide. Our coyotes know the schedule of the border patrols.
“郊狼”们开始大喊让我们趴低。该行动了。我们都像疯子冲进疯人院大门一样乱跑。布里吉里奥和我跑得很快。我们经过了十几名女销售员。首席“郊狼”奇基林示意我们跟着他到一个崖壁后面，我们都躲在那里。我们的“郊狼”知道边境巡逻的时间表。
One truck passes us, flashing lights and sirens. We all sprint to an abandoned building. A coyote hisses at us to hide, and we try. But two of the fake US Border Patrol trucks are racing toward us. And then the agents are out of the trucks and chasing us. And they're on us. And we're trapped. There's only one way out. And it's right through the middle of the Border Patrol.
一辆卡车从我们身边经过，亮着灯，拉着警笛。我们都冲向一座废弃的建筑。一个“郊狼”向我们发出嘶嘶声让我们躲起来，我们也照做了。但两辆假美国边境巡逻车正冲向我们。然后特工们从车里出来追赶我们。他们追上了我们。我们被困住了。只有一条路可以逃脱。就在边境巡逻队的中间。
Our coyotes run, so we run. Five or six Border Patrol agents are grabbing the rest of the salespeople right in front of me. One agent gets a hand on me, but I make it past him. There's gunfire, like I'm sure they're shooting blanks, but it's loud and it feels real. We all race away from the Border Patrol and lose them in a thicket of spiny plants. All I can think is, what the [BLEEP]?
我们的“郊狼”跑了，我们也跑了。五六个边境巡逻特工就在我面前抓住了剩下的销售人员。一个特工伸手抓我，但我绕过了他。有枪声，就像我确信他们开的是空包弹，但声音很大，感觉很真实。我们都从边境巡逻队那里跑开，在一片多刺植物丛中甩掉了他们。我只想，这他妈的是什么？
The salespeople are dead silent. Brigilio and I find each other, and I follow him up a narrow, rocky trail about mid-pack in the sales team. We walk a long way. It gives me time to recognize that the real US Border Patrol would probably not have blasted their sirens when they snuck up on us. And they probably wouldn't shoot into a crowd of migrants. This is the Mexican telenovela version of a border crossing, a dramatic reenactment. This is what sells tickets.
销售人员死一般寂静。布里吉里奥和我找到了对方，我跟着他沿着一条狭窄、崎岖的步道，处于销售团队的中段。我们走了很长一段路。这让我有时间意识到，真正的美国边境巡逻队在潜近我们时，可能不会拉响警笛。而且他们可能不会向移民人群开枪。这是墨西哥电视肥皂剧版的越境，一场戏剧性的重演。这就是卖票的原因。
That said, the salespeople have fully suspended their disbelief. They look totally freaked out. There's a barbed wire fence in front of us. We all scamper beneath it and circle around the eroded edge of a cliff. And then the coyotes start going crazy, motioning for us to get down. Before us, there's a dying campfire and a shack, like a little log house. And then there's this.
话虽如此，销售人员已经完全停止怀疑了。他们看起来完全吓坏了。我们前面有一道铁丝网围栏。我们都从它下面钻过，绕过悬崖被侵蚀的边缘。然后“郊狼”们开始疯狂地示意我们趴下。在我们面前，有一个快熄灭的营火和一个棚屋，像个小木屋。然后是这个。
[SHOUTING]
[大喊]
It's an old Indian man, not like a Hnahnu Indian, like an American Indian, like in the year 1823, an old Western, with a feathered headdress and a loincloth. He's carrying a rifle, an old Red Ryder looking thing. And he is not happy. He lights a torch. Chiquilin tries to tell him that we're just passing through, trying to get north. The Indian fires back with an angry bunch of words.
那是一个印第安老头，不像哈纳胡印第安人，像美国印第安人，像1823年，一部老西部片，戴着羽毛头饰，穿着缠腰布。他拿着一支步枪，看起来像旧时的红莱德步枪。他很不高兴。他点燃了一个火把。奇基林试图告诉他我们只是路过，试图去往北方。印第安人愤怒地回了一串话。
And then this small Indian woman comes out of the log house. There's just a lot of arguing, and I'm not understanding a word of it. The Indian shoots the old rifle into the air. Then two more shirtless Indians show up on the scene, like warriors. One's carrying a spear. This feels really fun to me, like John Wayne's going to come over the hill next.
然后这个矮小的印第安女人从木屋里出来。有很多争吵，我一个字也听不懂。印第安人向空中开了那支旧步枪。然后又有两个赤裸上身的印第安人出现在现场，像战士一样。一个拿着长矛。这对我来说感觉很有趣，就像约翰·韦恩接下来会翻过山丘一样。
The warriors grab one of our coyotes, El Tigre, I think. They tie him up to a cactus. Maybe it's a post. It's dark. One Indian holds a gun to his head, and the other holds a spear. A saleswoman beside me is clearly into it. She pleads our case, saying that we are Mexicans, and we're lost, and we just want to pass north.
战士们抓住了我们的一个“郊狼”，我想是埃尔蒂格雷。他们把他绑在仙人掌上。也许是柱子。天很黑。一个印第安人用枪指着他的头，另一个拿着长矛。我旁边的女销售员显然被吸引住了。她为我们辩护，说我们是墨西哥人，我们迷路了，只想去北方。
Mexicans? The old Indian says, like it was the magic word he'd been waiting for all along. He tells us to prove it, by singing the Mexican national anthem. Before the weirdness of that can sink in, Chiquilin starts us out. And the salespeople warm to it.
墨西哥人？印第安老头说，仿佛那是他一直在等待的魔法词。他告诉我们证明这一点，唱墨西哥国歌。在这种怪异感还没沉淀下来之前，奇基林带头唱了起来。销售人员开始热情回应。
[SINGING "HIMNO NACIONAL MEXICO"]
[唱“墨西哥国歌”]
The old Indian decides to let us pass, with a little more gunfire to help shoo us off.
印第安老头决定放我们过去，又开了几枪来帮我们赶走。
[GUNSHOT]
[枪声]
And we're running again. We run for a long time. Like, I don't even know why we're running now.
我们又跑了起来。我们跑了很长时间。我是说，我甚至不知道为什么现在还要跑。
Faster, James. Faster.
快点，詹姆斯。快点。
I ask Brigilio if he ever went through an Indian reservation when he crossed the real border. Once, he said, in Arizona. They didn't care. They just waved them through.
我问布里吉里奥，他在真正的边境越境时是否穿过印第安保留地。他说有一次，在亚利桑那州。他们不在乎。他们只是挥手让他们过去。
When we stop running, we walk. We walk for a long time. The walking is the opposite of exciting. It is monotonous. It's drudgery.
当我们停止奔跑时，我们开始行走。我们走了很长时间。行走与刺激相反。它是单调的。它是苦差事。
The salespeople are showing wear, shuffling their feet like prisoners in leg irons. One of the women appears to have twisted an ankle. She's leaning on another one of the salespeople for support. I'm not sure that this was the kind of team building they signed up for.
销售人员表现出疲态，像戴着脚镣的囚犯一样挪动脚步。其中一名女性似乎扭伤了脚踝。她靠在另一位销售员身上支撑。我不确定这就是他们报名的团建活动。
There's a mountain up ahead. I ask Brigilio if that's our destination. He says yeah. And I say I'm happy, because it looks close. Brigilio tells me he remembers having that exact same feeling looking at mountains when he crossed the border for real.
前面有一座山。我问布里吉里奥那是不是我们的目的地。他说是的。我说我很开心，因为它看起来很近。布里吉里奥告诉我，他记得在真实越境时看着山峰时有过完全一样的感觉。
You say, oh yeah. It's close. But it's not close.
你说，哦，是的。它很近。但它并不近。
I ask him if seeing the Border Patrol brought back any memories for him. He says no. But the walking does. We climb more hills, more rocky ledges, more dusty trails, more mud.
我问他看到边境巡逻队是否让他想起任何回忆。他说没有。但行走却会。我们爬了更多的山，更多的岩架，更多的尘土飞扬的步道，更多的泥地。
All the jostling makes my recorder switch itself on and off, and it makes me lose a pretty good chunk of important stuff. For example, I don't capture the sounds of the five guys who stop us on the trail, tattooed gang members like from the streets, with the baggy jeans and tank tops. When they can't find our money, they steal food from our coyote's backpack.
所有的颠簸导致我的录音机自动开关，这让我丢失了一大段重要的内容。例如，我没有捕捉到在步道上拦住我们的五个人，像街头黑帮一样有纹身，穿着松垮的牛仔裤和背心。当他们找不到我们的钱时，他们偷走了“郊狼”背包里的食物。
I also failed to record the encounter with the 20 members of a powerful drug cartel that surrounded us. These guys had everything-- big gestures, really angry voices, automatic weapons that looked really real. And the cartel boss wore gold chains, and he had this great aura of evil. They even took one of the women from our group and shot her in the head.
我也没能记录下与包围我们的20名强大贩毒集团成员的遭遇。这些人什么都有——大手势、非常愤怒的声音、看起来非常真实的自动武器。贩毒集团老板戴着金链子，有一股极好的邪恶光环。他们甚至从我们组里带走了一个女人，朝她头上开了一枪。
The salespeople were really traumatized by this one. She was one of the actors, and the cartel guys fake-threw her body off a cliff. Then after we ran some more and got ourselves clear of the murderous cartel, my recorder started working again.
销售人员真的被这一幕吓坏了。她是演员之一，贩毒集团的人假装把她的尸体扔下了悬崖。然后在我们又跑了一阵子，摆脱了那帮残忍的贩毒集团成员后，我的录音机又开始工作了。
Vamos! [SHOUTING]
走！[大喊]
It was nearly the end of the night. We reached a bluff that overlooks the highway. Our transportation, our ride, is scheduled to meet us here and deliver us to fake Phoenix. Brigilio tells me that this is a hot corridor, heavily patrolled by border agents. Chiquilin whispers that when the coast is clear, we'll go in groups of 10.
快到深夜了。我们到达了一个俯瞰高速公路的崖壁。我们的运输工具，我们的车，定于在这里接应我们并把我们送到假菲尼克斯。布里吉里奥告诉我，这是一个热点走廊，边境特工巡逻频繁。奇基林低声说，当海岸安全时，我们会分批10人一组进去。
The first group of salespeople scurries down the hill and is just about to jump in the back of the truck when trouble appears. Two Border Patrol trucks box them in. An agent speaks through the PA, tells the other agents to search them all. He asks where the coyote is and if there are any more of us. But nobody rats us out. They're all loaded into the Border Patrol truck and taken away.
第一批销售人员匆忙跑下山，正要跳上卡车后部时，麻烦出现了。两辆边境巡逻车把他们截住了。一名特工通过扩音器说话，告诉其他特工搜查他们所有人。他问“郊狼”在哪里，还有没有其他人。但没人告发我们。他们都被装上边境巡逻车带走了。
[SIRENS]
[警笛声]
We are, all of us, in disbelief. We've been walking for three hours. Everyone is silent. Brigilio signals that we're in the next group. It strikes me that I really want to make it, that I don't want to be one of the ones who gets caught. Three white pickups appear in the distance, our ride. 30 of us run down the hill. I'm waiting to hear the siren.
我们所有人都不敢相信。我们已经走了三个小时了。每个人都沉默了。布里吉里奥示意我们是下一组。这让我印象深刻，我真的很想成功，我不想成为被抓住的那一批人。三辆白色皮卡出现在远处，那是我们的车。我们30个人跑下山。我等着听警笛声。
Brigilio and I jump into the bed of the third truck. We force ourselves as flat as we can, and then I feel the truck shift into gear, and we're driving. We're going to make it.
布里吉里奥和我跳进第三辆车的车斗里。我们强迫自己尽可能平躺，然后我感到卡车换了档，我们开动了。我们要成功了。
We arrive at the safe house blindfolded. That's how coyotes protect the location of a safe house.
我们被蒙着眼睛到达了安全屋。那是“郊狼”保护安全屋位置的方法。
Vamos, vamos.
走，走。
Brigilio says that at a real safe house, we'd all be jammed into a room with a bunch of other migrants and forced to wait until our relatives paid off the final balance to the coyotes. And of course, that would be after two days and nights of walking through the desert, not just three hours.
布里吉里奥说，在真正的安全屋里，我们都会被挤进一个房间，里面还有一群其他移民，被迫等待直到我们的亲戚付清“郊狼”的余额。当然，那是在穿过沙漠走过两天两夜之后，而不仅仅是三个小时。
But we're led down a path to what feels like a grassy field. It sounds like we're next to a river. Chiquilin tells everybody to keep their blindfolds in place. And he says, tonight we gave you just a small sample of the dangers of crossing the border. Maybe 5% of what the real experience is like.
但我们被带到了一条小路上，那里感觉像是个草地。听起来我们就在河边。奇基林告诉每个人保持蒙眼状态。他说，今晚我们只给了你们一小部分越境危险的样本。也许只有真实体验的5%。
He delivers this rousing speech. This message is like a patriotic stay-in-school kind of thing, that Mexicans have a moral obligation to stay here in Mexico, to not cross the border and give all of their energies to another country. Give your energies to your own community, he says. Make this country great. He tells everybody that he's going to count to three, and then we're all going to remove our blindfolds.
他发表了一番激昂的演讲。这个信息就像一种爱国、留在学校之类的东西，墨西哥人有道德义务留在墨西哥，不要越境并把所有的精力贡献给另一个国家。把你的精力贡献给自己的社区，他说。让这个国家伟大起来。他告诉所有人他要数到三，然后我们全都摘下眼罩。
Uno, dos, tres!
一，二，三！
[SHRIEKS]
[尖叫]
Across the river in front of us is a tall bluff, maybe 200 feet high. It's covered top to bottom with hundreds of flaming torches, maybe thousands. The firelight dances on the surface of the river. It's surreal. Chiquilin asks if we know what the torches represent. One of the salespeople guesses correctly. Yes, Chiquilin says, we do it to honor our brothers and sisters who've lost their lives crossing the border.
我们面前的河对岸是一个高高的崖壁，大约200英尺高。它从上到下覆盖着数百个燃烧的火把，也许是几千个。火光在河面上跳动。这太超现实了。奇基林问我们是否知道这些火把代表什么。一位销售人员猜对了。是的，奇基林说，我们这样做是为了纪念那些在越境途中失去生命的兄弟姐妹。
The salespeople, they're really moved by all of this. Some look sort of misty-eyed. These stories are a big part of their national heritage, even though the reality of it's so far removed from their own lives. Chiquilin calls all of the salespeople to huddle in a big circle and hold hands. For the second time tonight, they sing Mexico's national anthem.
销售人员真的被这一切感动了。有些人看起来有点热泪盈眶。这些故事是他们国家遗产的重要部分，尽管现实离他们的生活太遥远了。奇基林呼吁所有销售人员聚成一个大圆圈手牵手。这是今晚第二次，他们唱起了墨西哥国歌。
[SINGING "HIMNO NACIONAL MEXICANO"]
[唱“墨西哥国歌”]
The other message from tonight is not about the future of Mexico or the dangers of a real border crossing. It's just about the reality of the Caminata itself and the fact that it even has to exist, the whole elaborate thing with all of its actors and costumes and staging and props, the endless reenactment of something that none of the Hnahnu wanted to do in the first place.
今晚的另一个信息不是关于墨西哥的未来或真实越境的危险。它只是关于“夜间步行”本身的现实，以及它甚至必须存在的事实，整个复杂的系统，所有的演员、服装、布景和道具，无休止地重演哈纳胡人本来不想做的事情。
Chiquilin said to the tourists, we started doing the Caminata because we were becoming a village of ghosts. This is all we've got. We have no professions, no education, no industry. This is what we have to do to survive here. But it's an experiment that hasn't paid off yet. They advertise these Caminatas, but sometimes they go for weeks without enough tourists to run one.
奇基林对游客说，我们开始做“夜间步行”是因为我们正在变成一个鬼村。这就是我们所有的一切。我们没有职业，没有教育，没有产业。为了生存，我们必须这样做。但这是一个尚未见效的实验。他们宣传这些“夜间步行”，但有时几周都没有足够的游客来开展一次。
And when there are enough tourists, like tonight, none of the actors gets paid by the village. This is not a job for anyone yet. Things here are still desperate. People go hungry. And the village still depends on money sent from the 80% of the Hnahnu who are living in the United States. Some of the actors from the Caminata told me that very soon they're heading north to try to cross the real border again.
当有足够游客时，比如今晚，没有一个演员能从村里拿到钱。这还不是任何人的工作。这里的情况仍然很绝望。人们挨饿。村庄仍然依赖于80%居住在美国的哈纳胡人寄回的钱。“夜间步行”的一些演员告诉我，很快他们就会去北方，再次尝试越过真正的边境。
James Spring in Hidalgo, Mexico. In July, the Caminata Nocturna will celebrate its 10th anniversary. James has done a Spanish language version of this story for Radio Ambulante, which is a radio show and a podcast modeled after our radio show but all in Spanish. If your language skills are good enough, you should check him out. We'll link to the Spanish language version of the story on our website, or you can just google your way there.
詹姆斯·斯普林在墨西哥伊达尔戈。7月，“夜间步行”将庆祝其10周年。詹姆斯为Radio Ambulante制作了这个故事的西班牙语版本，这是一个模仿我们广播节目的广播节目和播客，但全是西班牙语。如果你的语言能力足够好，你应该去看看。我们将把这个故事的西班牙语版本链接到我们的网站，或者你可以直接谷歌搜索找到它。
Act Two, Phone Home. So now we have a story about people moving the other way across the border, from the US to Mexico, yearning for homes here in the US, not there in Mexico. We deport from the United States about 250,000 people every year to Mexico. Over 100,000 more leave on their own. And there's an entire industry that has grown up around the fact that there are now tons of people living in Mexico who speak perfect American English. And that industry is call centers.
第二幕，电话回家。现在我们有一个故事，讲述的是人们反向穿越边境，从美国到墨西哥，渴望回到美国的家，而不是在墨西哥。我们每年从美国向墨西哥驱逐大约25万人。另有超过10万人自己离开。围绕着现在有大量居住在墨西哥且能说流利美式英语的人这一事实，出现了一个完整的行业。那个行业就是呼叫中心。
Over the last decade, American companies like Best Buy, Dish Network, Time Warner have been outsourcing their call center jobs to Mexico. And at first, these call centers just handled Spanish language calls from the United States. But then everybody realized, oh, they've got lots of really good English speakers there. And that became a big part of what those call centers now do.
在过去十年里，百思买、Dish Network、时代华纳等美国公司一直在将呼叫中心业务外包给墨西哥。起初，这些呼叫中心只是处理来自美国的西班牙语电话。但后来每个人都意识到，哦，他们那里有大量非常好的英语使用者。那成了这些呼叫中心现在所做工作的重要部分。
Seth Freed Wessler has talked to dozens of people in these jobs, though. And he says it can be a little weird for the people who work at the call centers.
赛斯·弗里德·韦斯勒曾与几十个从事这些工作的人交谈过。他说对于在呼叫中心工作的人来说，这可能有点怪。
These are pretty good jobs except for one thing-- they make you homesick. Lots of people who work at these call centers have just moved to Mexico, and they miss the United States. They miss their old lives. And at work, they spend hour after hour, call after call, talking to people who still have those lives. Maru Ponce left New York for Mexico when she graduated from college with a business degree and couldn't get a job because she didn't have papers. She got hired in Mexico taking calls for AT&T.
除了有一点外，这些都是相当不错的工作——它们让你想家。很多在呼叫中心工作的人刚搬到墨西哥，他们想念美国。他们想念过去的生活。而在工作中，他们花费一小时又一小时，一个电话又一个电话，与依然拥有那种生活的人交谈。马鲁·庞塞大学毕业时因为没有证件找不到工作，就离开了纽约去了墨西哥。她在墨西哥受雇为AT&T接听电话。
One guy who called and he's like, oh, yeah, we're going ice skating. And then we're going to dinner at Olive Garden or something. And I was like, oh, I used to do that with friends. So I would feel this churning. And sometimes I would stop listening to what they were saying, because in my head I'd be like, this memory and that memory when I used to go out with my friends. And they'd be like, hello, hello, are you still there?
有一个家伙打电话来，他说，哦，是的，我们要去滑冰。然后我们要去橄榄花园餐厅吃晚餐之类的。我当时就像，哦，我过去常和朋友那样做。所以我会感到心里一阵翻腾。有时我会停止听他们在说什么，因为我在脑子里想，这个回忆和那个回忆，当我过去常和朋友们出去玩的时候。他们会问，喂，喂，你还在吗？
When Maru would work the evening shift, over the phone she could hear customers doing the same things her family used to do back in Queens, like watching boxing matches.
当马鲁上晚班时，通过电话她能听到客户做着她家人过去在皇后区常做的事，比如看拳击比赛。
In the back, you hear the TV, like really loud. And I just remember thinking, oh, I wonder if my dad is watching it right now. Like I remember him leaning down on the couch, and he'd be like, oh, get me some soda, or get me something to eat. And it would be very clear in my head, seeing this family in this room that brought me back to the apartment that we used to live in in Astoria, Queens.
背景里，你听到电视声，非常大。我只记得当时在想，哦，我不知道我爸爸现在是不是在看这个。就像我记得他靠在沙发上，他会说，哦，给我拿点苏打水，或者给我拿点吃的。在我的脑海里非常清晰，看到这家人在这个房间里，带我回到了我们过去在阿斯托里亚，皇后区住的公寓。
You're like, oh, man, these people are calling from over there. And I just wish I could just go through this phone and be over there, you know? It's an overwhelming feeling of sadness.
你就像，哦，伙计，这些人是从那边打来的。我真希望我能直接穿过这部电话到那边去，你知道吗？那是一种压倒性的悲伤感。
This is Luis Roldan. He grew up in Orange County, California, got into some gang-related trouble, missed a court date, and got deported. And he says what makes these calls hard is that people call when they're out doing stuff, American stuff, running errands, driving, shopping. Sometimes they're waiting in line at fast food drive-throughs, ordering hamburgers or whatever. Like this lady.
这是路易斯·罗尔丹。他在加利福尼亚州奥兰治县长大，卷入了一些黑帮相关麻烦，错过了一次出庭日期，并被驱逐出境。他说让这些电话变得困难的是，人们在外面做事情、做美国人的事情、跑腿、开车、购物时打电话。有时他们在快餐店汽车穿梭窗口排队，点汉堡或其他什么。就像这位女士。
She called about her internet working. Oh, I'm just sitting here in the drive-through at Taco Bell. I'm like, oh man, are you kidding me? They have no Taco Bell here. It's just taco right here. There's no Bell. It's just taco. [LAUGHS]
她打电话询问网络故障。哦，我正坐在这里在塔可钟的汽车穿梭窗口。我就像，哦，老兄，你在开玩笑吗？他们这里没有塔可钟。这里只有炸玉米饼。没有“钟”。只有炸玉米饼。[笑]
What is it about Taco Bell?
塔可钟有什么特别的吗？
I don't know. American food itself. Jack in the Box, In-N-Out, Burger King, Carl's Jr. I mean, how many times I remember going through drive-throughs, you know?
我不知道。美国食物本身。杰克盒子，In-N-Out，汉堡王，卡乐星。我是说，我记得多少次开车穿梭窗口，你知道吗？
Luis isn't kidding. This came up again when I went out with him and his call center friends. We were eating at the best taqueria I've ever been to in my life. And this guy from North Carolina said, yeah, he also really misses Taco Bell.
路易斯不是在开玩笑。当我跟他和他的呼叫中心朋友出去时，这一点又出现了。我们在吃我一生中吃过的最好的炸玉米饼店。那个来自北卡罗来纳州的家伙说，是的，他也真的很想念塔可钟。
Actually, I do. I'm going to be honest, I do. I don't know, it's just a different flavor. It's the States flavor. You know you're in the States.
说实话，确实想。我会老实说，我确实想。我不知道，这只是不同的口味。这是美国味。你知道你在美国。
Luis says sometimes it messes with his head, hanging out with people who remind him of his friends in the States. And then speaking English all day to customers in an office that looks like  a cheesy American startup. There's a ping-pong table outside the cafeteria. Walls are painted neon green.
路易斯说有时这会扰乱他的思绪，与那些让他想起在美国的朋友的人混在一起。然后一整天用英语向客户讲话，在一个看起来像老套美国创业公司的办公室里。食堂外面有一张乒乓球桌。墙壁被漆成霓虹绿。
I don't know. I'm taking a call, and I'm just thinking, ah, I'm going to go home. And I look out the window, and the Mexican flag's right in front of me. Pwish. Reality just melts. And I can't believe I'm in Mexico City. I even say, what the hell am I doing here? I can't believe I'm in Mexico City.
我不知道。我正在接听电话，心里只想着，啊，我要回家了。我看向窗外，墨西哥国旗就在我面前。嗖。现实一下子融化了。我简直不敢相信我在墨西哥城。我甚至说，我他妈在这里做什么？我简直不敢相信我在墨西哥城。
Angel Perez came to Texas when he was two years old, lived in a small rural town called Graford, Texas, population 600. He spent his whole life there, graduated from high school, had a couple of kids. But then he got into some trouble, and eight months ago, got deported. Angel ended up in Mexico City, working for one of the biggest call centers, TeleTech.
安吉尔·佩雷斯两岁时来到得克萨斯州，住在一个叫格雷福德的小农村，人口600。他一生都住在那里，高中毕业，有了两个孩子。但他卷入了一些麻烦，八个月前被驱逐出境。安吉尔最终到了墨西哥城，为最大的呼叫中心之一 TeleTech 工作。
Lots of people told me they're supposed to keep conversations short, to around eight minutes. But Angel keeps his calls to two, because he's saving up his minutes. That way, he says, he can drag out calls with customers who remind him of home. Mostly people who live in the country, like this guy named Jim from Alabama.
很多人告诉我，他们应该保持通话简短，在八分钟左右。但安吉尔把电话控制在两分钟，因为他在攒时间。那样的话，他说，他可以拖延那些让他想起家乡的客户的电话。大多是住在农村的人，比如这个叫吉姆的阿拉巴马家伙。
He kept calling me Bubba. And that's one of my words that I use too, because I was raised with them redneck boys. So they use Bubba a lot, or Bub.
他一直叫我“布巴”。这也是我用的词之一，因为我是和那些乡下红脖子男孩一起长大的。所以他们经常用“布巴”或者“布”。
What did he call in for?
他打电话来为了什么？
Well, he called in, just saying, hey, listen here, Bubba, like my bill's up. I don't even know why, and this and that. Man, I'm a country boy here. I don't know none of this technology.
嗯，他打来，就说，嘿，听着，布巴，我的账单怎么了。我甚至不知道为什么，这个那个的。老兄，我是个乡下孩子。我不懂这些技术。
I said, I know, I feel you. I said, I'm in Mexico City right now. And I was in Texas, out in the country. And he goes, oh, Bubba, man, you need to go back. Hurry up and come back to Texas. I said, I know. I am, I'm trying. So--
我说，我懂，我理解。我说，我正处在墨西哥城。我过去在得克萨斯州，在农村。他说，哦，布巴，老兄，你需要回去。快点回到得克萨斯。我说，我知道。我正努力回去。所以——
Yeah, we talked I'm going to say at least 25 to 30 minutes [INAUDIBLE] on that call, just talking about hunting, fishing, out in the river swimming. I used to just lay back on a roof, on a car. And we'd just sit there and just look up there and see shooting stars, because it's so black, and everything's so clear. And here, you don't see nothing. Well, I still haven't seen-- I don't even bother looking up at the sky at night no more.
是的，我们谈了，我可以说至少25到30分钟[听不清]那通电话，只是谈论狩猎、钓鱼、在河里游泳。我过去常躺在屋顶上，在车上。我们只是坐在那里，抬头看天，看流星，因为那里太黑了，一切都那么清晰。而在那儿，你看不到任何东西。好吧，我还没看到——我甚至不再费心去抬头看晚上的天空了。
Right now, there's a $6 billion a year industry in Mexico that does customer service calls, billing, and IT for people who don't live in Mexico. At the rate it's growing, the industry will double in the next five years. And it's benefiting from the hundreds of thousands of people who get deported from the US each year.
现在，墨西哥有一个每年60亿美元的行业，为不住在墨西哥的人提供客户服务、账单和IT支持。以它发展的速度，这个行业将在未来五年翻倍。而且它受益于每年从美国驱逐出境的数十万人。
One of the companies told me that the Mexican government sometimes gives out job information at the border about call centers to deportees. And the outsourcing companies, they're keeping track of the cities where people are settling and then opening up new facilities there. When Angel arrived, he found odd jobs, like moving furniture for $15 a day, which is typical. Other deportees told me about working at a car wash or a soap factory, at a restaurant or hauling fish off a boat. All those jobs pay $10 to $20 a day.
其中一家公司告诉我，墨西哥政府有时会在边境向被驱逐者分发关于呼叫中心的工作信息。而外包公司正在追踪人们定居的城市，并在那里开设新设施。当安吉尔到达时，他找到了一些零工，比如搬家具每天15美元，这是典型的。其他被驱逐者告诉我关于在洗车店或肥皂厂工作，在餐厅工作或从船上卸鱼。所有这些工作每天支付10到20美元。
Call center jobs start around $40 a day. That's a good middle class wage in Mexico. These jobs are desirable. Mexican kids come out of college and try to get them. But for the most part, these call centers are like little islands of expats in Mexico. The agents who work there, they hang out with each other. They date each other. Sometimes they even marry each other.
呼叫中心的工作每天开始约40美元。那是墨西哥相当不错的中产阶级工资。这些工作很受欢迎。墨西哥的孩子大学毕业后会尝试争取它们。但大多数情况下，这些呼叫中心就像墨西哥的外籍人士小岛。在那里工作的代理人，他们互相在一起玩。他们约会。有时甚至互相结婚。
Angel's group of friends are all guys from Texas, just like him. Only most of them aren't from the country like Angel. They're from cities, Dallas and Houston. A lot were in gangs. Now that they hang out all the time, Angel's been trying out their shtick. Like he's thinking about becoming a rapper. One Tuesday night, I go out with Angel and his friends to a bar that looks like an American diner. They sit in a booth getting wasted off 40's.
安吉尔的朋友圈都是来自得克萨斯州的家伙，就像他一样。只是他们大多数不像安吉尔那样来自农村。他们来自城市，达拉斯和休斯敦。很多人进过黑帮。现在他们整天混在一起，安吉尔一直在尝试他们的那一套。比如他正考虑成为一名说唱歌手。一个周二晚上，我和安吉尔以及他的朋友们去了一家看起来像美国快餐店的酒吧。他们坐在卡座里喝着大瓶装啤酒喝得酩酊大醉。
We put music on. We smoke weed. We drink. We rap. (RAPPING) I'm a Texas boy that wasn't born, but I was a Mexican man that was deported from the TX--
我们放音乐。我们抽大麻。我们喝酒。我们说唱。（说唱）我是个没出生的得克萨斯男孩，但我是一个被得克萨斯驱逐的墨西哥男人——
They go on like this for about half an hour, getting louder. Almost all of their lyrics are about Texas. Then some preppy Mexican guys at the table next to them start getting annoyed and shush them.
他们这样持续了大约半小时，声音越来越大。他们几乎所有的歌词都是关于得克萨斯。然后旁边桌上的几个穿着时髦的墨西哥家伙开始变得恼火并嘘他们。
--way back in the gang.
——回到帮派里。
Shh!
嘘！
Hey, man, that be the name--
嘿，老兄，那就是名字——
Shh!
嘘！
Eventually, the bartender gets fed up too, and goes to the music system.
最终，酒保也受够了，走到音乐系统前。
--and they free-styling about my lifestyle. Stand up, and I'm gonna shoot you, bitch--
——他们即兴说唱关于我的生活方式。站起来，我要开枪打你，碧池——
[MEXICAN MUSIC PLAYING]
[播放墨西哥音乐]
Here in Mexico, some of these call center workers still make a turkey every year for Thanksgiving. Remember, these are people who couldn't even get driver's licenses when they lived in the US.
在墨西哥，一些呼叫中心员工每年感恩节仍然会做一只火鸡。记住，这些人当他们住在美国时甚至拿不到驾照。
Other Mexicans notice they're not from here. They stick out. They dress differently. They walk differently. Their arms are covered in tattoos. And they go around in big groups speaking English. That can make locals mad.
其他墨西哥人注意到他们不是本地人。他们很显眼。他们穿着不同。走路不同。他们的手臂布满纹身。他们成群结队地说英语。这会让当地人很生气。
This happened to Luis the other day, when he was on the subway. His girlfriend, who's also from the States, called him on his cell.
前几天路易斯就遇到过这种情况，当时他在地铁上。他的女朋友，也是来自美国，用手机打给他。
I answer the phone call. Hello? And this guy notices my accent right away. I noticed him from my periphery. He just turned around, and he starts staring at me. So I keep talking, oh, I'm going to be home in the next 10 minutes, whatever. And he told me, you're in Mexico. You need to be speaking in Spanish. He used the word "bocho," which is a word that they use towards Mexican-American. It's a derogatory term.
我接了电话。喂？那个家伙立刻注意到了我的口音。我从余光里注意到了他。他转过身，开始盯着我。所以我继续说话，哦，我十分钟内到家，随便吧。他告诉我，你在墨西哥。你需要说西班牙语。他用了“bocho”这个词，这是一个他们用来称呼墨西哥裔美国人的词。这是一个贬义词。
Locals look down at people who have come back. They see them as screw-ups who got kicked out of the US and can't speak proper Spanish. But it's complicated, because they also resent the advantages these returnees have, their English and these jobs that pay so well.
当地人看不起回来的人。他们把他们看作是被踢出美国、不会说地道西班牙语的失败者。但这很复杂，因为他们也怨恨这些回归者拥有的优势，他们的英语和这些薪水很高的工作。
People see them as uppity. They're too American. But actual Americans also give them attitude. They get flak all the time from callers in the States who are annoyed to find themselves talking to someone in Mexico.
人们认为他们傲慢。他们太美国化了。但真正的美国人也对他们态度不好。他们经常受到在美国的客户的攻击，那些客户很恼火发现自己在和墨西哥的人说话。
The other day, in fact, I had a call. It was a customer. He's like, well, you have an accent. And I was like, well, I'll do the best I can. And he said, where am I calling to? Mexico City, sir, in a very pleasant tone. He said, why, you [BLEEP] wetback. And I took off my earpiece. And he hung up.
事实上前几天，我接了一个电话。那是个客户。他说，嗯，你有口音。我说，好吧，我会尽力的。他说，我打到哪里去了？墨西哥城，先生，用一种非常愉快的语气。他说，为什么，你他妈的“湿背”（非法移民）。我摘下了耳机。然后他挂了。
I talked to over 50 call center workers, and the ones who've been here the longest said it gets easier after a while. The job becomes just what it is, short transactions over the phone with strangers. Eventually you don't get so homesick. Maru says that's how it worked for her. She's been here for eight years now and no longer wishes she lived in the US.
我和50多名呼叫中心员工谈过，那些在这里待得最久的人说一段时间后会变得容易。工作就变成它本来的样子，通过电话与陌生人进行的简短交易。最终你不会那么想家。马鲁说这对她就是这样。她已经在墨西哥待了八年，不再希望住在那里了。
And it's also like this thing where it's like there's this country that didn't want me. Why do I want to go back to somebody or to something that didn't want me and accept me? Like if it was a relationship, it's like, why go back to my ex when there are so many better things? And there's a world out there.
而且就像有一件事，好像有个国家不想要我。为什么我要回到一个不想要我、不接受我的人或事身边？如果是一段关系，就像，为什么在有这么多更好的东西时回到前任身边？外面还有一个世界。
Angel has only been living in Mexico for eight months. And every day at the call center is still a struggle for him.
安吉尔在墨西哥只住了八个月。呼叫中心的每一天对他来说仍然是一种挣扎。
I hate this job. I hate it. I hate it with a passion, but it's the only thing that helps me make money here.
我讨厌这份工作。我讨厌它。我带着激情讨厌它，但这是我在墨西哥赚钱的唯一途径。
I mean, do you think about going back to the US?
我是说，你想过回到美国吗？
Yeah, I think about going back every minute. Every time I take that call, first call, I want to go back. I don't care if I have to carry a big old  bag of drugs. I don't care what I have to do. If they gave me the opportunity to go back, I'd go back. But I know I can't. There's this thing telling me, just don't-- don't go back.
是的，我每分钟都在想回去。每一次我接那个电话，第一通电话，我都想回去。我不在乎是不是要带一大包毒品。我不在乎我要做什么。如果他们给我机会回去，我会回去。但我知道我不能。有东西告诉我，别——别回去。
How long do you think you'll live in Mexico?
你觉得你会在这儿住多久？
Well, probably the rest of my life. That's another thing that bugs me when I take calls, knowing that this is it. This is as far as you're getting is you're going to be here for the rest of your life in Mexico taking calls.
嗯，可能是余生。当我接电话时，这是另一件困扰我的事，知道就是这样了。这就是你得到的，你将在墨西哥余生都接听电话。
Lately, Angel's been missing a lot of work. But he doesn't care if he gets fired. He says he'll just find another job at another call center. There's more of them all the time.
最近，安吉尔经常旷工。但他不在乎是否被解雇。他说他会去另一个呼叫中心找另一份工作。那里的工作总是在增加。
Seth Freed Wessler. Coming up, it's hip to be square and made of carbohydrates. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
赛斯·弗里德·韦斯勒。接下来，平庸也是一种潮流，且由碳水化合物构成。那是一分钟后来自芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际的节目，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, "There's No Place Like Home," stories of people doing unusual things to create or preserve or hold onto a home for themselves. We've arrived at Act Three of our program. Act Three, The Hostess with the Toast-ess.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们选择一个主题，带给你们关于那个主题的不同故事。今天的节目，“没有像家一样的地方”，讲述人们做不寻常的事情来创造、保留或留住家园的故事。我们已经到达节目的第三幕。第三幕，带吐司的女主人。
John Gravois moved with his wife and daughters a year and a half ago across the country to San Francisco. And he has been very aware of the ways that San Francisco seems different from the rest of the country. Recently, he noticed something new happening around the Bay Area, which turned out to be not what he thought at all. Here's John.
约翰·格拉沃伊斯一年半前带着妻子和女儿跨越全国搬到了旧金山。他一直非常意识到旧金山似乎与全国其他地方不同的方式。最近，他注意到湾区出现了一些新东西，结果发现根本不是他想的那样。这是约翰。
A few months ago, I was standing in line at a coffee shop on my way to work. And I couldn't stop staring at this guy behind the counter. He was cutting inch-thick slices of bread, putting them in a toaster, and spreading stuff on them.
几个月前，我在上班路上的咖啡店排队。我无法停止盯着柜台后面的那个家伙。他正在切一英寸厚的面包片，把它们放进烤面包机，然后在上面抹东西。
But it was the way he did it that caught my attention. He had the solemn intensity of a ping-pong player who keeps his game very close to the table, knees slightly bent, wrist flicking the butter knife back and forth, his eyes suggesting a kind of flow state. In front of him, laid out in a neat row, were a few long Pullman loaves, that boxy Wonder Bread shape, but recognizably handmade and freshly baked.
但他做这件事的方式吸引了我的注意。他有着乒乓球手那种严肃的专注度，膝盖微弯，手腕来回轻弹黄油刀，眼睛暗示着一种流畅的状态。在他面前，整齐地排列着几条长普尔曼面包，那种盒装Wonder面包形状，但明显是手工制作且新鲜出炉的。
On the menu, toast stood all on its own as an option at $3 per slice. So I ordered some. It was good. It tasted like toast, only better.
菜单上，吐司作为一个选项，每片售价3美元。所以我点了一些。很好吃。吃起来像吐司，只是更好吃。
A couple of weeks later, I stumbled across another place with a self-described toast bar. Then another. This third place I went to was like a temple to hot, sliced bread. It was called The Mill, a big, light-filled cafe and bakery with exposed rafters and polished concrete floors, like a rustic Apple store, with a small chalkboard listing the day's toast menu.
几周后，我偶然发现了另一个有自称吐司吧的地方。然后是另一个。我去的第三个地方简直是一座热面包片的圣殿。它叫“磨坊”，一家光线充足的大型咖啡馆和面包店，有着外露的椽木和抛光混凝土地板，像一家乡村风格的苹果商店，还有一块写着当天吐司菜单的小黑板。
I asked the manager at one of these places what was going on. Why all the toast? Tip of the hipster spear, he said. And then I realized what this meant. Toast, like the cupcake and the dill pickle before it, had been elevated to the artisanal plane.
我问其中一家店的经理这到底是怎么回事。为什么这么多吐司？他说，这是潮人长矛的尖端。然后我意识到这意味着什么。吐司，像之前的杯子蛋糕和腌黄瓜一样，已经被提升到了工艺品的层面。
I had two reactions to this. First, of course, I rolled my eyes. How silly. How precious. How perfectly San Francisco. Artisanal toast. And second, despite myself, I felt a little thrill of discovery. As a 35-year-old guy with a wife and two kids, I'm usually the last to find out about a trend.
我对这个有两个反应。首先，当然，我翻了个白眼。多么愚蠢。多么矫情。多么典型的旧金山。工艺吐司。第二，尽管我不愿意，但我感到了一点发现的快感。作为一个有妻子和两个孩子的35岁男人，我通常是最后一个发现趋势的人。
But here I was, apparently standing up on the artisanal toast wave, way before it crashed into Brooklyn, Chicago, and Los Angeles, before the inevitable article in Slate telling people that they're making toast all wrong, before the even more inevitable backlash by angry bloggers.
但在这里，我显然站在工艺吐司浪潮的巅峰，远在它冲击布鲁克林、芝加哥和洛杉矶之前，在Slate那篇必然出现的文章告诉人们他们做吐司的方式全都错了之前，在愤怒的博客作者必然会产生强烈抵制之前。
I decided to go looking for the origins of the fancy toast trend. How does such a thing get started? What determines how far it goes? Maybe I thought it would help me understand the rise of all of the seemingly trivial things that start in San Francisco and then go supernova across the country. And just as I began searching, the backlash arrived.
我决定去寻找高级吐司趋势的起源。这样的事情是如何开始的？什么决定了它走多远？也许我想这会帮助我理解所有这些似乎微不足道的事情的兴起，它们在旧金山开始，然后席卷全国。就在我开始搜索时，抵制到来了。
The local media started running articles with headlines like "$4 Toast-- Why the Tech Industry is Ruining San Francisco." And almost all of the blaming fingers pointed at The Mill. So I figured, bingo. That's Ground Zero.
当地媒体开始刊登标题为“4美元的吐司——为什么科技行业正在毁掉旧金山”的文章。几乎所有指责的手指都指向“磨坊”。所以我心想，宾果。那就是震中。
[TRAFFIC NOISE]
[交通噪音]
Wow. It's really crowded.
哇。人真多。
[DOOR OPENS]
[门开了]
But one of the owners there, Josey Baker-- yes, he's a baker, and yes, that's his name-- told me he was not the originator of this craze.
但那里的老板之一，乔西·贝克——是的，他是个面包师，是的，那是他的名字——告诉我他不是这股狂热的始作俑者。
Yeah, I mean, there was one other place here in the city, and they mostly do cinnamon sugar toast.
是的，我是说，城里还有另一家店，他们主要做肉桂糖吐司。
No, Josey wasn't the Chuck Berry of fancy toast. He was more like the Elvis of fancy toast, a guy who caught the trend when it was already on an upswing. The place he first saw it, four or five years ago, is out in one of San Francisco's windiest, foggiest, farthest-flung areas, the Outer Sunset. Other toast professionals sent me to the same cafe.
不，乔西不是高级吐司的查克·贝里。他更像是高级吐司的猫王，一个在趋势已经处于上升期时才赶上的家伙。他四五年前第一次看到它的地方，是在旧金山最刮风、最多雾、最偏远地区之一，外落日区。其他吐司专业人士把我送到了同一家咖啡馆。
It's completely different from any of the other places serving toast. For one thing, it's about 10 times smaller. In fact, it's nothing like what I expected. And the story behind it-- the story of the person who started this trend-- made the trend itself feel like an embarrassingly tiny thing to focus on.
它和这里供应吐司的其他任何地方都完全不同。首先，它小了10倍。事实上，它一点也不像我预期的那样。而它背后的故事——那个开启这个趋势的人的故事——让这个趋势本身感觉像是一个令人尴尬的小焦点。
So I'm going to tell you that story. But first I should tell you the name of the place. It's called The Trouble Coffee and Coconut Club, otherwise known simply as Trouble.
所以我打算告诉你那个故事。但首先我应该告诉你这个地方的名字。它叫“麻烦咖啡与椰子俱乐部”，也就是俗称的“麻烦”。
Trouble's really popular. It always seems to have a line going out the door. And because the shop is the size of a single car garage, it's cramped and crowded with artifacts and wall hangings, like a very personal museum.
“麻烦”真的很受欢迎。它似乎总是有排队排到门口的现象。而且因为店面只有单车车库那么大，它拥挤不堪，摆满了艺术品和墙挂，就像一个非常个人的博物馆。
I got two toasts on the bar.
我在吧台点了两份吐司。
On the menu are four main items. Coffee, cinnamon toast, coconuts, and shots of grapefruit juice named after Yoko Ono.
菜单上有四样主要项目。咖啡，肉桂吐司，椰子，和以小野洋子命名的葡萄汁。
One toast for David.
一份给大卫的吐司。
The founder of Trouble is Giulietta Carrelli. And every one of those menu items has a defined significance to her, as does her never changing wardrobe. She's always in a sleeveless crop top, ripped jeans, and a head scarf. She's covered in tattoos, including her cheeks, which are tattooed with freckles and always flushed, like a biker Pippi Longstocking.
“麻烦”的创始人是朱莉叶塔·卡雷利。菜单上的每一项对她来说都有明确的意义，她那从不改变的衣着也是如此。她总是穿着无袖露脐上衣、破洞牛仔裤和头巾。她身上布满了纹身，包括脸颊，那上面纹着雀斑，总是泛红，像个骑摩托车的皮皮长袜子。
We're going to have to move the drum kit today.
我们今天得移动鼓组。
And yes, she confirms it. She says it took a long time for the rest of San Francisco to copy her toast idea. Trouble is the kind of place where you might walk in and feel excluded, like I guess I'm not hipster enough for all this. That's kind of the way I felt at first.
是的，她证实了这一点。她说旧金山的其他地方复制她的吐司想法花了很长时间。在这个地方，你走进去可能会感到被排除在外，就像我猜我还没时髦到那种程度。起初我就是那种感觉。
But then Giulietta told me something that made Trouble and the purpose of it snap into focus. Trouble isn't just the name of Giulietta's coffee shop. Trouble is her word for a psychotic episode, the kind she's had since she was 16, growing up in Cleveland. Her official diagnosis is schizoaffective disorder, but she only learned that recently. And back when the episodes first started, in high school, she had no idea what was wrong with her.
但后来朱莉叶塔告诉我的一件事让“麻烦”及其目的变得聚焦。不仅是朱莉叶塔咖啡店的名字。是她对精神病发作的词，从16岁在克利夫兰长大起她就一直这样。她正式的诊断是分裂情感性障碍，但她最近才知道。早在高中第一次发作时，她根本不知道自己出了什么问题。
I started having these things where I thought people were putting LSD in my beer. I was hallucinating. And so when things would get weird, I just thought that's what was happening, that people put acid or that I drank mushroom tea. And I was hanging out with people who partied pretty hard, so I thought that's what was happening.
我开始有这些想法，我以为人们在我的啤酒里放了LSD。我在产生幻觉。所以当事情变得奇怪时，我只是认为这就是发生了什么，人们放了酸，或者我喝了蘑菇茶。我当时和一些派对玩得很疯的人混在一起，所以我认为发生了这些。
I would try to be in class-- let's say it's an English class or something-- but I was outside of my body watching myself be in the class. And that's what happens to me a lot. And all the voices were very, very, very loud. And like if you could hear people crumbling the paper, and it was just so uncomfortable. This is where I was just yesterday, sitting outside, not being able to even go to Trouble. I was in that state of mind yesterday.
我会试图在课堂上——比如英语课什么的——但我是在自己的身体之外看着自己坐在教室里。那是经常发生在我身上的事情。所有的声音都非常非常非常大。如果你能听到人们揉皱纸张的声音，那真是太不舒服了。这就是我昨天所处的状态，坐在外面，甚至无法去“麻烦”。昨天我处于那种精神状态。
During an episode, sometimes she hears voices or gets the sense that she doesn't actually exist. Also, eating is difficult. She can't stand the sound of her own chewing. After ruling out her LSD theory, she thought maybe she was just having lots of nervous breakdowns. Then came the theory that she was bipolar. She was even medicated for bipolar disorder.
在发作期间，有时她会听到声音或者感觉自己根本不存在。此外，进食很困难。她无法忍受自己咀嚼的声音。在排除了她的LSD理论后，她认为也许她只是有很多次神经崩溃。然后有了她是双相情感障碍的理论。她甚至因为双相情感障碍接受了药物治疗。
Then I just thought this is me. And everything's my fault. I just destroy relationships. I can't hold an apartment. I can't hold a job. I'm nice enough. I try my best. This is just who I am. So that's how I went about.
然后我只认为这就是我。一切都是我的错。我只是破坏关系。我无法租到公寓。我无法保住一份工作。我足够友善。我尽力了。这就是我。所以我就那样继续生活。
She somehow managed to put herself through college, three different colleges, in different corners of the country, by booking shows for underground bands and working at record stores and coffee shops. But Giulietta's illness was a kind of time bomb that eventually leveled any structure in her life. Roommates kicked her out. Romances fell apart. Her bosses either fired her or quietly stopped scheduling her for shifts.
她不知何故设法读完了大学，三所不同的大学，在全国不同的角落，通过为地下乐队预订演出，在唱片店和咖啡店工作。但朱莉叶塔的疾病就像一个定时炸弹，最终铲平了她生活中的任何结构。室友把她踢了出去。恋情破碎。她的老板要么解雇她，要么悄悄停止为她安排班次。
A lot of the time, she was pretty much homeless. She slept in her car, on lots of couches. For a little while, she slept in a tree. By the time she hit 30, she had lived in nine different cities.
很多时候，她几乎是无家可归。她睡在车里，在很多沙发上。有一段时间，她睡在一棵树上。到30岁时，她已经在九个不同的城市住过了。
She first came here, to the Bay Area, as a student at Berkeley. And she remembers this one episode, a long, delusional walk through San Francisco, during which she called the police to let them know a tree had fallen on top of her, which it hadn't. And finally Giulietta found herself at China Beach, in the northwest part of town. On the sun deck was an elderly man sitting on a towel, wearing a Speedo, sunbathing on a cloudy day that suggested anything but. This would be the beginning of the beginning for Giulietta and for Trouble Coffee-- the moment she met Glen.
她第一次来到这里，来到湾区，是作为伯克利的学生。她记得那次发作，一次长时间的妄想，穿越旧金山的步行，期间她打电话给警察，让他们知道一棵树倒在了她身上，其实并没有。最终朱莉叶塔发现自己在唐人滩，在城的西北部。在太阳甲板上，有一个老人在毛巾上坐着，穿着三角泳裤，在阴天里日光浴，那天气一点也不适合。这对朱莉叶塔和“麻烦咖啡”来说，将是开始的开始——她遇见格伦的那一刻。
Little, little man. Really petite. White hair. His socks always matched his sweater, no matter what. I was always amazed by that. But he was mostly in a Speedo, tanning. No tanning lotion, like no SPF for Glen.
小，小小的人。非常娇小。白头发。他的袜子总是和毛衣匹配，不管是什么情况。我对此一直很惊奇。但他大多数时间穿着三角泳裤，晒太阳。没有防晒霜，比如对格伦来说没有SPF。
Glen, whose real name is Gunther Neustadt, was a Holocaust survivor who escaped Germany as a boy. Anybody who went to China Beach regularly back then will tell you he was a fixture there. But more than Glen that first day, Giulietta was struck by a pair of Russian men, climbing out of the ocean after a swim. I should mention here that almost year round, the water at China Beach is cold enough to make you hypothermic after a few minutes.
格伦，真名叫冈瑟·纽斯塔特，是一名大屠杀幸存者，童年时逃离了德国。当时任何经常去唐人滩的人都会告诉你他是那里的常客。但比起那天第一次见到的格伦，朱莉叶塔更被两个从海里游泳出来后爬上岸的俄罗斯男人震惊了。我应该在这里提到，几乎全年，唐人滩的水冷到让你几分钟内就会体温过低。
These strong men, just coming out of the ocean. And I was so weak. I was the walking dead. I wanted to be that strong. And they came up onto that sun deck, and they were so alive.
这些强壮的男人，刚从海里出来。而我太虚弱了。我是行尸走肉。我想像那样强壮。他们走上那个太阳甲板，他们是那么有活力。
So I started asking Glen about these men. And he told me that people swam there regularly, all these people. And I was like, this is what I want to do. But anyways, I didn't last in San Francisco. I went on to all my little stints.
所以我开始问格伦关于这些人的事。他告诉我，人们经常在那里游泳，所有人。我就像，这就是我想做的。但不管怎样，我在旧金山没待多久。我继续我所有的小段经历。
First to South Carolina, then Georgia, where she hit upon the first in a series of coping mechanisms that she still uses-- coconuts. For some reason, coconuts are the one food that doesn't feel like poison when Giulietta is in an episode. And the chewing sound isn't as bad. And not to sound like an infomercial for coconuts, they're really nutritious. Giulietta says you can survive on them, provided you have a source of Vitamin C, hence the grapefruit juice on Trouble's menu.
先是去南卡罗来纳州，然后是佐治亚州，在那里她发现了她至今仍在使用的 coping 机制系列中的第一个——椰子。出于某种原因，椰子是朱莉叶塔在发作时感觉不像毒药的唯一食物。咀嚼的声音也没那么糟糕。不是为了听起来像椰子的电视购物广告，它们真的很有营养。朱莉叶塔说你可以靠它们生存，只要你有维生素C的来源，这就是“麻烦”菜单上有葡萄汁的原因。
Another great thing about coconuts, people talk to you when you're holding one. Giulietta has studies to prove it, studies she performed herself, standing on a sidewalk, noting down how many strangers engage with her when she's holding a sandwich versus when she was holding a coconut. It wasn't even close.
椰子的另一个好处是，当你拿着它时人们会和你说话。朱莉叶塔有研究证明这一点，她亲自做的研究，站在人行道上，记录当她拿着三明治时，有多少陌生人与她交谈，以及当她拿着椰子时，又有多少。简直没法比。
All of a sudden, I found something that would keep me alive. It didn't bother me chewing. I felt great. And people talked to me. I was like, this is working.
突然，我找到了能让我活下去的东西。我不介意咀嚼了。我感觉很好。人们也和我说话。我心想，这招奏效了。
Still, she was barely sleeping and self-medicating a lot with pills, mostly Vicodin and whiskey. She was away from San Francisco for four or five years.
不过，她仍然几乎睡不着，而且经常用药物自我治疗，主要是维柯丁和威士忌。她离开旧金山有四五年了。
Then one day, I was at a party, and I thought about that old man and those old Russian men at China Beach. And the next day, because my roommate was pretty much done with me, I rented a car and went straight to China Beach.
然后有一天，我在一个聚会上，我想起了那个老人和唐人滩的那些老俄罗斯人。第二天，因为我的室友几乎受够了我，我租了一辆车，径直去了唐人滩。
And then when you got there?
然后当你到那里时？
Glen was there. And he told me that it took me a long time to come back. He was like, where have you been? So actually, this is Glen's corner.
格伦在那里。他告诉我，我回来花了很长时间。他就像，你去哪了？所以实际上，这是格伦的角落。
Giulietta took me to China Beach, to the spot on the sun deck where she started hanging out with Glen after she came back. Talking with him every day, the routine of it, was the next thing she found that really helped her. At the end of every visit, he'd say the same thing. See you tomorrow.
朱莉叶塔带我去了唐人滩，带到了她回来后开始和格伦混在一起的太阳甲板上的那个位置。每天和他交谈，这种例行公事是她找到的另一件真正有帮助的事情。每次访问结束时，他都会说同样的话。明天见。
Soon she started joining the other swimmers at China Beach. She swims every day now at about the same time. When she's having an episode, the cold water can shock her out of hallucinating.
很快，她开始加入唐人滩的其他游泳者。她现在每天大约在同一时间游泳。当她发作时，冷水可以震慑她，让她摆脱幻觉。
It's fu-- oh man, I'm cold. [SHIVERING]
fu——哦老兄，我好冷。[颤抖]
Giulietta got the idea for Trouble in 2005. But it wasn't so much an idea as a whirlwind of coconuts and strangers meeting each other and cinnamon toast, all swirling around in her mind. She was working in a coffee shop at the time, always button-holing customers and coworkers about her plans.
朱莉叶塔在2005年有了“麻烦”的想法。但这与其说是一个想法，不如说是一阵椰子和陌生人相遇、肉桂吐司的旋风，在她的脑海里盘旋。当时她在一家咖啡店工作，总是向客户和同事滔滔不绝地讲她的计划。
She did the same with Glen, who brought the idea down to earth, telling her point blank to open a checking account, go to City Hall, and ask them about starting a small business. And her boss at the coffee shop found her sleeping there once or twice, and rather than say you're fired, he said, I think it's time for you to open your own place.
她对格伦也做了同样的事，他把这个想法落实到地面上，直截了当地告诉她开个银行账户，去市政厅，向他们询问关于开办小型企业的事。她在咖啡店的老板有一次两次发现她在那里睡觉，与其说你被解雇了，他反倒说，我想是你该开一家自己的店的时候了。
Then he told me, he was like, just get some cups, brew some coffee. When you run out of cups, close the door and go get more cups.
然后他告诉我，他就像，只要买些杯子，泡咖啡。当你杯子用完时，关门去买更多的杯子。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
And that was my business advice.
那就是我的商业建议。
With barely any money, she landed a five-year lease in the Outer Sunset, in a former doggy day spa that seemed to have been a front for some kind of crystal meth operation. So here was a shop that sells coconuts and toast in a crummy part of town that nobody went to, run by a person with a significant mental illness.
几乎没钱，她在外落日区租了一份五年租约，在一个前宠物日间水疗中心，看起来像是一个某种晶体甲基苯丙胺操作的前台。所以这家店就在没人去的破烂地区卖椰子和吐司，由一个患有重大精神疾病的人经营。
But I never, ever, ever thought that it was going to fail. Everything that works for me, I put in one little spot. And I thought, well, if it works for me, it'll work for other people.
但我从没，从没，从没想过它会失败。所有对我奏效的东西，我都放在一个小地方。我想，嗯，如果它对我奏效，它对其他人也会奏效。
She put coconuts on the menu because of the times she'd relied on them for easy sustenance. And because they did help her strike up conversations.
她把椰子放在菜单上，因为她曾依靠它们获得轻松的维持。而且因为它们确实帮助她开始对话。
What about toast?
吐司呢？
My mom used to make me toast. And so when I was first opening up Trouble, I wanted to feel safe. Toast was that for me. And I also knew it was going to be that for a lot of people. Nobody can be mad at toast. I mean, it's toast. It's cinnamon toast. Everybody's stoked.
我妈妈过去常给我做吐司。所以当我第一次开“麻烦”时，我想感到安全。吐司对我来说就是那种感觉。我也知道这对很多人来说也会是那种感觉。没人能对吐司生气。我是说，它是吐司。它是肉桂吐司。每个人都很兴奋。
In 2012, so just two years ago, Giulietta finally got the definitive diagnosis of schizoaffective disorder and medication that genuinely helps keep the episodes at bay. She stopped drinking and taking drugs a long time ago. But the major way she's managed to cope with her episodes when they happen is by creating a network of people and turning herself into a local institution, which is what she's been doing, bit by bit, ever since she came back to San Francisco from New York. At first, it was just the people she saw in her daily bike route to and from China Beach.
在2012年，也就是两年前，朱莉叶塔终于得到了分裂情感性障碍的确定诊断，并且药物确实有助于控制发作。她很久以前就停止饮酒和吸毒了。但她设法应对发作的主要方式是建立一个人员网络，并把自己变成一个当地的机构，这正是她自从从纽约回到旧金山后一直在做的，一点一点地。起初，这只是她每天骑自行车往返唐人滩时见到的人。
And I would talk to the city workers who were building things. So just in case I wasn't doing well, they would remember me. They saw me every day. And sometimes I would ask them if they could help me get somewhere.
我会和那些正在建造东西的城市工人交谈。以防我状态不好，他们会记得我。他们每天都见到我。有时我会问他们是否能帮我到达某个地方。
Huh. What do you say?
嗯。你说什么？
I tell them that I can't see very well right now. My mind is racing. I'm supposed to make it to work. I'm late. Can you help me? I've knocked on people's doors.
我告诉他们我现在看不太清。我的大脑在飞速运转。我本该去上班的。我迟到了。你能帮我吗？我敲过人们的门。
You just knock on their door and say--
你只是敲他们的门说——
Excuse me. I don't know where I'm going. Can you help me?
打扰一下。我不知道我要去哪。你能帮我吗？
This is why she wears the same outfit every day-- the crop tops and the head scarves. It's why she's covered herself with tattoos-- so people will recognize her. And it's why she takes the same routes, day in and day out, around San Francisco-- so she can be recognized. When people interact with her, say hello on the street or call her name, it can do the same thing that cold water does when she swims-- knock her back into herself. It can mean the difference between her getting home or wandering lost around the city. And it's one of the reasons why she created Trouble.
这就是她为什么每天都穿同样的衣服——露脐上衣和头巾。这就是为什么她用纹身覆盖自己——这样人们就会认出她。这就是为什么她日复一日地在旧金山走同样的路线——这样她就能被认出来。当人们与她互动，在街上问好或叫她的名字时，这可以产生和她游泳时冷水一样的效果——把她打回她自己。这可能意味着她回到家或在城市里迷路徘徊之间的区别。这也是她创立“麻烦”的原因之一。
There's just so many people connected through this network of Trouble Coffee. I may just be a little tiny place, but it's pretty well-known, because I need to be well-known. I mean, I was just walking to my house before you guys got here. And it was this man with his son, and he goes, hey, you're Trouble, right? And I just went, I sure am.
通过“麻烦咖啡”这个网络连接的人实在太多了。我可能只是一个小地方，但它相当出名，因为我需要出名。我是说，你们来之前我正走回家。有个男人带着他的儿子，他走过来，嘿，你是“麻烦”，对吧？我只是说，我确定我是。
Fancy toast isn't what Trouble's about. It's just the weird chunk of the spaceship that broke off and landed in the rest of the world's front lawn. But in a way, it makes perfect sense that the trend started with Giulietta. Most of us dedicate the bulk of our attention to a handful of relationships-- with a significant other, children, parents, a few close friends. Social scientists call these strong ties.
高级吐司不是“麻烦”的目的。它只是飞船上断裂并落在世界其余部分前草坪上的那块怪东西。但从某种意义上说，趋势从朱莉叶塔开始是非常合理的。我们大多数人把大部分注意力集中在少数几段关系上——与另一半、孩子、父母、几个亲密朋友。社会科学家称这些为强关系。
But for Giulietta, those kinds of strong ties have a way of buckling under the weight of her illness. So she's adapted by forming as many relationships, as many weak ties, as she possibly can. And webs of weak ties are how ideas spread, ideas like, in this case, toast.
但对于朱莉叶塔来说，那些强关系往往会在她疾病的重压下弯曲。所以她通过尽可能多地建立关系，尽可能多的弱关系，来适应。而弱关系的网就是想法传播的方式，就像在这种情况下，吐司。
John Gravois. He wrote a version of this story, a great version, for Pacific Standard Magazine , where he's an editor. By the way, you can't really live on coconuts and grapefruit juice. Not for long. Don't try it.
约翰·格拉沃伊斯。他为《太平洋标准杂志》写了这个故事的一个版本，一个伟大的版本，他是那里的编辑。顺便说一句，你真的不能靠椰子和葡萄汁生活。不能长久。别试。
[MUSIC - "COMIN' HOME" BY ROBERT ELLIS]
[音乐 - “回家” - 罗伯特·埃利斯]
Well, the program was produced today by Ben Calhoun, with Alex Blumberg, Sean Cole, Stephanie Foo, Sarah Koenig, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from Allison Davis. Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our production manager. Elise Bergerson's our administrative assistant.
嗯，节目今天由本·卡尔霍恩制作，与亚历克斯·布隆伯格、肖恩·科尔、斯蒂芬妮·福、莎拉·柯尼格、美纪·米克、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、布莱恩·里德、罗宾·塞米恩、艾丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克合作。我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。艾莉森·戴维斯提供制作帮助。赛斯·林德是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康登是我们的制作经理。伊莉斯·伯格森是我们的行政助理。
Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Research help today from Michelle Harris and Julie Beer. Music help from Damien Graef and Rob Geddis.
艾德丽安·马蒂奥维茨运营我们的网站。今天研究帮助来自米歇尔·哈里斯和朱莉·比尔。音乐帮助来自达米安·格拉夫和罗伯·格迪斯。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播国际发行。
Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Torey Malatia. You know, why does he always look so great? Well, it's because he spends his workdays outside with his computer, no matter what the weather is.
一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚。你知道，为什么他总是看起来那么棒？嗯，那是因为他无论天气如何，都把工作时间花在外面用他的电脑。
Mostly in a Speedo, tanning, no tanning lotion.
大多数时候穿着三角泳裤，晒太阳，没有防晒霜。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
[MUSIC - "COMIN' HOME" BY ROBERT ELLIS]
[音乐 - “回家” - 罗伯特·埃利斯]
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。